mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonjour connaîtrons-nous une pause en
cette fin de semaine dans ces affaires
nationales et internationales qui se
sont développées au cours de ces jours
derniers rien n'est moins certain
ainsi au proche orient l'aviation
égyptienne poursuit ses raids sur les
positions israéliennes tandis qu'un
journal américain annonce que les états
unis auraient finalement décidé de
vendre des avions militaires à israël
à bruxelles une nouvelle importante
accord global
cette nuit sur le financement de
l'europe verte mais si vous voulez nous
allons pour ce samedi
abandonné à l'instant ces problèmes et
nous tourner vers les sports vers le ski
les championnats du monde vous le savez
ont virtuellement commencé ce matin en
italie à val gardena et michel drucker
tous les coureurs maintenant donc ont
accepté de disputer ces épreuves de
qualification oui en effet après un
moment de mauvaise humeur
toutes les vedettes étaient au départ de
ce fameux slalom de qualification qui
s'est déroulée dans d'excellentes
conditions il faisait très beau sur la
vallée de gardena qui vous le savez sans
doute est situé dans les dolomites à
l'extrême nord de l'italie à proximité
de la frontière autrichienne
la neige était en excellente état
température 2 à 3 degrés est comme prévu
il n'y a pas eu de grosse surprise dans
ce slalom de qualification toutes les
vedettes tous les favoris se sont
qualifiés chez les français russell oger
peines et bréchet ont passé facilement
ce cap des qualifications
chez les étrangers tony l'italien s'est
qualifié lui aussi le sujet giovanoli
également stans également meissner son
compatriote aussi un seul faux pas celui
d'un autre autrichien herbert hoover qui
a abandonné dans sa série et il va
disputer dans quelques instants les
repêchages mais l'ibère qui est un
excellent slalomeur devrait se qualifier
aisément nous allons voir la
qualification de patrick russel nous
avons choisi russell tard c'est le celui
qui est en tête de la coupe du monde de
ski c'est le meilleur slalomeur actuel
et vous allez voir le français qui
appartenaient il ya quelques années au
grenoble université club s'est fort bien
comporté sur cette piste qui était
longue de 575 m
comprenez 62 porte dénivellation 157 9
royer russell s'est très facilement
qualifiés ils avaient à battre il est
vrai dans sa série 4 skieurs inconnus ou
peu connus un allemand un tchèque un
américain et un russe
55 secondes 63 centièmes pour russell
qui a réalisé de très loin plus de deux
secondes d'avancé sur le second le très
loin donc le meilleur corps de sa soeur
je vous rappelle que le titre mondial de
slalom spécial sera décerné demain matin
à val gardena et russell vous le voyez
sont ces images est en très grande forme
il est le favori du spécial avec
l'italien toni le suisse du minck
giovannoni il a gagné tous les services
spéciaux depuis le début de la saison
par ailleurs je voulais dit bréchet jean
noël augert et pen se sont fort bien
comportés
voilà c'est fini pour russell que nous
verrons demain pour finale pour le titre
cette fois le titre officiel de champion
du monde de slalom spécial il est le
favori
mauvaise nouvelle pour l'autriche il
s'agit là de l'équipe féminine de ski
anne-marie preuve s'est blessé hier elle
souffre d'une distorsion des ligaments
internes du genou gauche des
infiltrations lui ont été faites par le
médecin de l'équipe d'autriche elle
devra observer un repos complet
elle reposera probablement les skis
lundi et fera un essai et elle décidera
si oui ou non elle participe à la non
stop et à la descente qui aura lieu le
mardi 10 février ce serait un coup dur
pour l'équipe d'autriche car anne marie
paule est sans doute le meilleur élément
un des meilleurs éléments de l'équipe
féminine patinage artistique à leningrad
aux championnats d'europe après le titre
des femmes reportez vous le savez hier
par l'allemande de l'est gabriel seifert
ce sont les couples de danseurs qui sont
au prix cet après midi chez les
messieurs se terminent actuellement les
figures imposées nous allons voir une
photo de patrick paiera ici patrick
perrin est actuellement second après les
deux premières figures imposées mais à
deux points seulement du tchèque n'est
pas là qui est le favori de ces
championnats d'europe nous serons ce
soir si l'écart a grandi ou non et si
perras a des chances de l'emporter
demain au cours des figures libres
football le week-end est consacré aux
32e là je change de sujet 32e de finale
de la coupe de france de match oppose le
savez des équipes professionnelles de
division 1 demain c'est le grand choc
lille marseille a lancé cet après midi
au parc des princes en gérant contre
angoulême deux équipes qui connaissent
bien la coupe de france ce match sera
télévisé en direct tout à l'heure
à partir de 15 heures athlétisme enfin
les critériums nationaux ont commencé
hier soir crédits nationaux en salle à
la city national des sports une grande
performance a été réalisée au cours de
cette première soirée cinq mètres 20 à
la perche par le français traquent
années lycée la meilleure performance
européenne junior en salle claude mais
dieu s'est entretenu avec racanelli
après cet exploit c est ce au cours du
concours mon premier essai à cinq mètres
en retombant j'ai pris mon jeu unique
sur la figure en face sur la lèvre
vous allez franche et 5 mètres 20 au 2e
essai pourquoi avez vous manqué le
premier basse et ça c'est un peu la
suite de la blessure ça saignait
abondamment de la lèvre et j'en avais
plein la bouche en phase a commencé à se
coaguler au fond et ça saigne ça saigne
et très fort alors je pensais surtout à
sa cette blessure et puis mon saut qui
s'est passé un peu comme ça moi j'ai pas
très pensée et là où jacques rocher
évidemment 5 mètres 20 c'est la
meilleure performance française la
meilleure performance européens en salle
et 2,5 m 23
la meilleure performance mondiale et de
5 mètres 32 et pourtant vous avez fait
placé la barre à 5 mètres 40 pourquoi
est ce que les records ne vous intéresse
pas oui c'est surtout sur les uns que
les records ne m'intéresse pas enfin
c'est quand même une manière de faire
d'une pierre deux coups il faut voir les
deux ensemble mais en fallait les
concours en effet ne m'intéresse pas
tellement ce que ce qui m'intéresse
surtout c'est de gagner des concours de
battre des adversaires puis si leur
corps se trouve au bout évidemment on en
profite mais comme ça les records sur
commande son intéressement maurice
houvion vous êtes l'entraîneur en
quelque sorte de francs soit racanelli
est ce que ces cinq mètres 5 puis 5
mètres 10 à poitiers 5 mai devant alien
s sont une progression logique
ou bien est-ce que cela vous surprend de
la part de votre élève non je pense que
les saints mais demain nous les
attendions s'était empressé était prévu
tcd
cette tête est prétentieux de dire qu'on
avait prévu cinq vagues enfin c'était la
suite logique des choses et je ne pense
pas que c'est dû à une forme optimum non
je crois que c'est c'est dans la suite
normale de sa progression 5 mètres
quarante est ce que ce n'était pas un
peu présomptueux de la part de tracas
nelly bien coûter alors ce qui me
concerne il est bien certain que si
j'avais été à sa place j'aurais pas miss
1 m 40
m'enfin françois à lui la faculté de se
concentrer une faculté extraordinaire
qui à mon avis vous très largement ses
qualités physiques et ma foi on peut
s'attendre à tout avec lui
lorsqu'on possède cette qualité
inventant de nouvelles donc au niveau
européen en effet à bruxelles cette nuit
accord des ministres des six sur
l'europe agricole bernard uthurry le
conseil des ministes des six abouti à
cette heure ce matin après 22 heures de
délibérations absolument in a des
revenus l'accord est globale il porte
sur le financement de l'europe verte
dans le courant de la nuit les six sont
successivement entendu sur le règlement
financier définitif de la politique
agricole commune c'est une chose
les pouvoirs du parlement européen de
choses et le marché commun du tabac
troisième chose ils ont enfin approuvé
les principes de l'organisation du
marché du vin en sortant de la réunion à
7h ce matin le ministre français des
affaires étrangères monsieur vrai
showman a déclaré eh bien les
pessimistes avaient tort l'esprit
européen l'a emporté à noter à propos de
l'organisation du marché du tabac qu'il
a été décidé que le monopole d'état
disparaîtra en 1976 ce qui veut dire
tout simplement qu'à partir de cette
date là vous pourrez si vous le voulez
acheter vos cigarettes je ne sais pas
chez le plombier ou chez le cordonnier
enfin pas nécessairement dans les débits
de tabac monsieur pierre harmel ministre
belge a déclaré en sortant il a déclaré
aux journalistes ce qui aurait pu nous
retenir est maintenant en arrière on
n'aurait pas pu progresser dans
l'élargissement de la communauté
si nous n'avions pas fait ce travail
nous passons tout de suite au proche
orient
je pense que nous avons également
derrière un film sur ce qui se passe en
ce moment en italie où ce qui risque de
se passer voici
à bruxelles les six se sont mis d'accord
sur le financement de l'europe verte
l'accord est intervenu à 7h ce matin
après 22 heures de négociations
ininterrompue paradoxalement l'imminence
de la démission du gouvernement italien
à accélérer le règlement des problèmes
en suspens par exemple celui des
pouvoirs budgétaires
1 données à l'assemblée parlementaire
européenne sur ce point les français et
les hollandais sont finalement parvenus
à un compromis
les ministres des six pays ont également
réglementer les derniers marchés qui
échappaient jusqu'à présent à l'emprise
communautaire celui du tabac et celui du
vin à propos de l'élargissement de la
communauté
les pourparlers auraient pris également
un bon départ notamment en ce qui
concerne l'entrée éventuelle de la
grande-bretagne de la norvège du
danemark et de l'irlande dans le marché
comme le gouvernement démocrate chrétien
italien présidé par monsieur mariano
rumor est démissionnaire la décision
officielle rendue publique ce matin n'a
rien de surprenant on l'attendait depuis
plusieurs jours et l'on peut même dire
que cette crise a été préparé à la suite
des difficultés politiques et sociales
de ces derniers mois la démocratie
chrétienne qui gouverne seul depuis la
crise de l'été dernier accentué sa
pression pour que soirée constituer un
gouvernement de coalition de
centre-gauche démocratie chrétienne
parti socialiste italien sociaux
démocrates des républicains qui auraient
plus de poids dans le pays pour faire
face aux difficultés actuelles nous
disait tout à l'heure pierre opsis notre
correspondant à rome est bien proche
orient maintenant vous lisez dans la
bruyère donc de nouvelles importantes
un raid israélien d'une part et cette
affaire donc dévoiler enfin entre
vizille maître par un journal américain
la livraison éventuel d'arc donc à
israël et d'avions américain à israël il
c'est un avion s'être d'avion c'est un
journal américain qui a donné cette
nouvelle les avions seront donc
américain également le gouvernement
nixon a décidé de vendre à israël de
nouveaux avions à réaction et d'autres
matériels militaires que ce pays a
commandé à l'automne dernier c'est ce
qu'indique aujourd'hui le new york times
qui cite des milieux officiels de
washington voici les deux appareils vous
venez les voir il y avait un skyblog et
un avion fantôme la décision porte sur
105 appareils au moins elle a été prise
elle aurait été prise
ce journal par le président nixon à la
suite de la réception du message de
monsieur kossyguine samedi dernier c'est
ce que précise le new york times les
avions ne serait livrables qu'en 1971
toujours selon ce journal
l'autre nouvelle du proche-orient
concerne la libye dans les milieux
diplomatiques libyens de tripoli
organise fille de complètement inexacte
et sans fondement l'information donnée
aujourd'hui par la radio israélienne
selon laquelle le colonel kadhafi le
colonel kadhafi l'homme fort du nouveau
régime de tripoli a été blessé dans un
attentat ya deux semaines d'ailleurs le
colonel kadhafi va bientôt se rendre au
caire au petit sommet arabe qui se tient
la baille dont nous parle de langeais
arsenal dans la capitale égyptienne
depuis jeudi le roi hussein de jordanie
a déjà eu des entretiens privés avec le
colonel nasser avant le petit sommet
arabe qui s'est ouvert ce matin ils
participent également les chefs d'état
de la syrie le docteur attassi et du
soudan le colonel et nimeiri le chef de
l'état irakien à lui n'a pas fait le
voyage et s'est fait représenté par l'un
de ses ministres
pour le quotidien du caire al ahram ce
petit sommet examinera la grave
situation militaire qui règne sur tous
les fronts avec israël mais il semble
que des divergences ce serait déjà fait
sentir entre les positions du colonel
nasser et du roi hussein face aux
syriens et aux irakiens
partisan d'une intensification de la
guerre monsieur arafat le représentant
palestinien qui participent au débat est
aussi de cet avis
france maintenant bien sur le plan
politique c'est donc la fin de la
semaine la pause
exception faite pour le parti communiste
français à nanterre le congrès consacre
ses deux dernières journées à l'étude
des grandes thèses du parti et aux
élections des dirigeants mais certains
délégués de la fédération du nord ne
seront pas à nanterre aujourd'hui il
assiste aux obsèques de leurs camarades
de la mine de fouquières-lès-lens tué
mercredi par un coup de grisou obsèques
officielles auxquelles participe en ce
moment même toutes les personnalités de
la région et notamment le ministre
monsieur françois xavier ortoli le temps
plus froid plus froid et surtout moins
pluvieux devrait permettre pour ce
week-end une décrue des fleuves et des
cours d'eau dans l'est et le bassin
parisien qui avait atteint la côte
d'alerté plus froid cela veut dire en
langage de moby liste verglas alors
attention aux accidents semblables à
celui que nous montre ce document et qui
nous parvient à l'instant de notre
station de reims 100 m de verglas sur la
route nationale 44 entre reims et
châlons sur marne route longue de 42 km
100 m de verglas qui ont coûté la vie à
cinq personnes
c'était ce matin vers 9h jusqu'à
l'embranchement de la rn44 à celle de
bar-le-duc sur cette route à quatre
voies séparées par un terre-plein une
504 venant de chalon et se rendant vers
reims à vive allure dérape sur une bande
verglacée franchi le terre-plein et
vient s'écraser contre une 4l arrivant
en sens inverse et à grande vitesse vous
imaginez facilement en voyant ces images
qu'elle fut la violence du choc des
voitures complètement disloqué ont
retiré cinq corps sans vie
cinq femmes âgées de 20 à 30 ans
je le répète le temps donc sera plus
froid sur les routes de france pendant
ce week end nouvelle scientifique
française maintenant la fusée diamant
vous savez celle qui lance nous
satellite sera très bientôt utiliser en
guyane mais c'est pour l'instant à
bordeaux qu'elle subit ces derniers
tests et technique nous sommes saint
médard en jalles près de bordeaux c'est
là que le centre national d'études
spatiales le cnes a procédé à
l'assemblage et aux essais de la
première fusée diamant b avant
l'expédition de ses étages en guyane
entre 1965 et 1967
la france a placé quatre satellites sur
orbite à l'aide de la fusée diamant à la
nouvelle version à premier et troisième
étages améliorer permettra de lancer des
satellites 2 à 3 fois plus lourd voilà
le troisième étage diamant b surmonté
d'une capsule technologique baptisée mik
son rôle sera de vérifier le
fonctionnement des trois étages de la
fusée et de sa case à équipements c'est
à dire son cerveau si tout fonctionne
normalement
mika sera placé sur orbite bien que son
rôle soit alors terminé à saint médard
la fusée a été contrôlée dans les
conditions les plus proches de celles
qui seront rencontrés lors du véritable
lancement
pendant ce temps où centre spatial de
brétigny et en allemagne les techniciens
terminé les essais du satellite
scientifique vicat qui sera confiée à la
même fusée
il s'agit en effet d'une expérience
réalisée en coopération franco-allemande
qui portera le nom de diane
les spécialistes sont confiants dans le
succès de ce premier essai de cette
nouvelle fusée française le premier
étage a été essayé plusieurs fois avec
succès ou à l'air béate vernon lancement
depuis le centre spatial guyanais est
prévue pour le 9 mars
et bien pour terminer ce journal
maintenant une page automobile si vous
le voulez depuis quelques années
maintenant vous l'avez sans doute
remarqué toute une série de voitures et
de préférence de petites cylindrées sont
bardées de bande adhésive privé
d'enjoliveurs gonflé c'est le mot bourg
et d'accessoires et manifestement
bricolé par des fanatiques de la
conduite dite rallye et cette clientèle
précisément de fanatiques intéresse de
plus en plus les constructeurs français
alors à partir d'un modèle de série et
dans les bonnes limites on vous livre
maintenant la voiture de monsieur tout
le monde
mais une voiture quand même pas tout à
fait comme les autres
sur tous les circuits français se sont
en effet le plus souvent ses berlines
bariolés aux lignes de voiture de tous
les jours qui apporte le plus de
sensations fortes aux spectateurs plus
de 11000 gordini vendu 300 engagés dans
la coupe qui porte leur nom il y avait
de quoi faire réfléchir tous les
construire d'autre part les grands noms
de l'automobile se lance maintenant dans
la compétition avec des moyens
spectaculaires comme vient de le
rappeler par exemple le rallye de monte
carlo
il y a donc maintenant une demande en
jeune technicien et quelquefois rêve
suprême en pilote professionnel c'est au
nom de ce rêve que le jeune
automobiliste de 1970 transforme souvent
sa berline de père de famille en l'un de
ces monstres couvert de décalcomanies
publicitaire effet de son marchand
d'accessoires le confident de ses
ambitions mécanique
bref tout ce qui fait sport fait vendre
c'est l'un des dernières découvertes des
services de marketing depuis un an
fleurissent sur les capots les initiales
est spécial tgs
il s'agit de donner aux consommateurs se
marchent pieds qui le fera un jour
entrer dans le club financièrement fermé
des propriétaires de grands tubes
et voici la dernière née non simca vrai
nom 1000 rallye recettes le moteur d'une
psy show sur la carrosserie d'une quatre
chevaux de la marque une seule couleur
rouge orangé et bien sûr de bandes
noires qui barre le capot
pour les spécialistes elle vaut un peu
plus de 37 secondes km 11 118
centimètres cubes 53 chevaux 5800 tout
non seulement il ya une clientèle pour
la voiture sportive mais c'est une
clientèle qui va en croissant à un
rythme assez extraordinaire lamy la ali
peut-on dire c'est la voiture sur mesure
pour le jeune qui veut s'approcher
sérieusement la khalid nous sommes
partis de la caisse de l'asim 4 qui a
tout ce qu'il faut mais pas de superflu
et nous l'avons habillé de tous les
composants spécifiques qu un rallyman
jusqu'à présent devaient fournir à
l'extérieur dans le détail vous voyez
par exemple que le siège du pilote est
un siège baquet que le volant est un
volant sport que tout l'ensemble du
tableau de bord on prend des instruments
et cadrans circulaires notamment un
contour qui est monté en série c'est
très appréciable en rallye ne
craignez-vous pas de donner un goût
exagérée de la vitesse et du risque à
une couche jeunes de population qui peut
être n'est pas encore prête à utiliser
de telles voitures
je crois qu'on contraire en mettant
entre les mains des garçons une voiture
qui le permet qui leur permet de
s'exprimer de façon à droite on évitera
les bricolages et on évitera aussi tous
ces grands prix il consiste à mettre un
numéro sur la portière et à faire le
tour de la grande place du village
voyez claude manuel nous rappelle que
cette voiture vous 37 secondes mais
aussi aux alentours de 8500 francs et
bien voilà maintenant cette édition donc
de 13 heures est terminée et mes
camarades et moi même vous souhaitons un
bon week-end nous retrouvons henri tisot
même